E aí
[Música]
e eu tenho uma memória muito forte muito
específica da minha infância e quando eu
tinha mais ou menos uns dez anos eu
estava no colégio católico e bastante
Nacional do Rio e num dos times de
futebol que a gente tinha toda semana um
amigo meu fez uma brincadeira comigo na
hora do intervalo que a gente fazer para
tomar água e quando eu tava no final do
bebedouro ele chegou pelo lado e disse
de errado eu acho que você fizer alguma
coisa para que seu pé na hora como eu
tava com as duas mãos apoiadas no
Bebedouro eu fiz o que parecia ser mais
longe para mim eu dobrei o joelho para
conseguir ver a sola do pé por cima do
mundo mas foi só fazer esse movimento
aqui que eu comecei a chupar risada aí
todo mundo ele tem dia que eu tinha
caído na brincadeira Olá eu sou Rio
falava ao pé de bailarina pé de
mulherzinha essas coisas essa
brincadeira que as crianças de hoje
problema gente ainda fazem era uma
espécie de teste de masculinidade EA
maneira como limpar meu pé é o jeito
errado de olhar o jeito certo ele assim
dobrando pela frente em outras palavras
Esse é o jeito de homem de olhar para o
próprio pé naquela hora como qualquer
criança acostumada com essas
brincadeiras eu fiquei com vergonha mas
eu também achei graça junto só que foi
também a partir desse momento ainda bem
novo eu comecei a entender que
Dependendo da forma como eu falava como
eu me movia como eu levo para a mão ou
pé alguma leitura ser feita sobre a
minha masculinidade e isso para mim era
uma preocupação enorme eu era o Caçula
de uma família simples e conservadora
quase toda de homens Engenheiros
militares e vejo muito pequeno eu já
sabia que eu era diferente eu só não
consigo entender naquela época que eu
era gay porque se nunca tivesse ensinado
para mim eu não tinha uma referência
disso a Internet ainda era novidade
a fazer filmes que chegaram a tocar
nesse assunto era um sempre na forma de
tragédia um negócio então só consegui
associar o fato de eu ser diferente
algum defeito Irreversível na minha
masculinidade que eu precisava esconder
a Qualquer Custo e compensar sendo o
mais macho possível só que até hoje eu
tô bastante convencido de que quando as
pessoas me conhecem elas problema de
pensão que eu imponho é hoje que eu
Controlo a minha maneira de gesticular
de me mover e mesmo que não coisa que eu
não consegue mudar naturalmente eu
reconheço que eu faço isso porque eu
aprendi desde criança a microgerencia
último de movimento para me enquadrar
dentro do que não entendia como
masculino e não demorou muito para sua
rigidez comportamento que me acompanha
durante toda a adolescência vida adulta
e além do físico e começar a influenciar
a forma EA forma de pensar só minha
forma de tomar decisões ou de lidar com
o sentimento difícil de como
vulnerabilidade e fragilidade fazem
parte do amadurecimento de qualquer
homem
e hoje em dia a gente fala cada vez mais
sobre isso geralmente com o nome de
masculinidade tóxica essa ideia de que
não precisa ser macho seguram terror de
grossa tá sempre do controle são todos
os códigos e definir o que é citar o
jeito de homem Esses códigos começam a
ficar bastante difícil para mim e quando
eu tinha já uns 20 anos e eu não
conseguia mais não falar sobre a minha
sexualidade e foi a partir da série
comecei viver abertamente como homem gay
para minha família os meus amigos na
faculdade no trabalho eu tive o
privilégio tem uma família que me
respeitou nesse processo mas come todo
mundo em torno isso não era algo normal
amigos que eu tinha se afastaram eu
passei a ser menos bem recebido em
lugares que eu fui contavam comecei a
ter dificuldade um trabalho que eu nunca
tinha tido antes e fui aprendendo dali
em diante a conviver com preconceito na
minha vida só que esse preconceito não
vim só de fora ele virá especialmente de
dentro aquela cobrança que eu tinha da
minha masculinidade continuava existindo
mesmo depois você sair do armário e já
chegou uma hora que eu pensei que parar
E aí vem para tentar entender por
exemplo o que que me fez achar durante
tanto tempo que o simples ato de pedir
ajuda era uma demonstração de fraqueza
ou ser sensível era um defeito em mim ou
então se pro seu homem de verdade o que
que é enorme tudo que pudesse ser
feminino e quando eu falei para
reconhecer essa masculinidade tóxica que
claramente tinha dentro de mim eu
comecei a entender o papel que ela
acabou entrando na minha vida e como é
importante falar sobre isso porque não
sei se a gente consegue por exemplo
realmente entender confrontar machismo
homofobia a misoginia ou qualquer outra
forma de discriminação sem fazer o
esforço de reconhecer que nós mesmo
provavelmente Temos vários nesse
preconceito às vezes sem perceber e
muito provavelmente em perceber também
um mal que não falar sobre isso faz para
própria saúde para dar um exemplo de
como ser um problema bastante sério um
estudo feito no Brasil 2019 com homens e
mulheres revelou que para quase Metade
dos homens entrevistados a depressão
e como exagero ou até mesmo sendo aqui
no Brasil a taxa de suicídio entre os
homens é 4 vezes maior do que entre as
mulheres esse mesmo estudo indica também
que formas de apoio a questões
emocionais como por exemplo a terapia
ainda são pouco valorizadas pelos homens
e aí sempre um lugar seguro para falar
sobre isso eles recorrem com mais
facilidade a violência ou diferentes
formas meses e não é muito difícil mas
não Impacto negativo disso um país onde
a cada 7 minutos uma mulher é vítima de
violência doméstica e por dia a gente
tem cerca de 22 crimes movidos por
homofobia praticamente um por hora ou
seja se a cultura do macho ela não é só
tosse ela pode ser perigosa todo mundo
pagou para esse lixo
e isso foi me incomodando um ponto e que
eu cheguei ao ponto de eu sentia que eu
pensava falar sobre isso pensava estudar
esse assunto eu pensava me conectar com
outras pessoas também queriam falar
sobre isso e esse exercício Acabou
também Impacto positivo bem maior do que
imaginava na minha vida tão Positivo eu
me comprometi a fazer disso um hábito e
de atrás de tudo aquilo que pudesse me
ajudar nesse processo de desintoxicação
por exemplo eu sempre adorei jogar
futebol e eu não preciso nem comentar o
com o machista universo do Esporte e
nenhum como especialmente assistiu o
futebol é para ninguém mas depois de
algum tempo aqui em São Paulo eu tive
meu primeiro contato com o movimento
crescente de homens gays que se juntou
prova do futebol e eu assim como fazer
na escola na faculdade eu fui aparecendo
nos trens mesmo sabendo que eu não jogo
tão bem e mesmo praticamente não conheço
ninguém ali só que dessa vez a inveja
entrar em quadra me preocupando com que
os caras eu pensar de mim eu tava no
espaço a gente jogava ali no fundo rosa
choque o mascote do time Conheci um
os campeonatos eram narrados por
drag queen e os trens eram bem mais
divertidos porque ninguém ficava com
jeito que você era hoje que você falava
a graça Lira justamente fazer graça
dessa rede deles comportamento de para
mim sempre foi a norma
é E essas experiências tão legal com
futebol e aqui essa fruta com quase 30
anos de idade deixou claro para mim como
essa minha preocupação constante com a
leitura que faziam da minha
masculinidade Acabou me deixando fechado
para tanta coisa durante tanto tempo e
eu não quis mais fechar essa porta mesmo
tempo tanta habilidade eu fui treinando
diferente aqui Participei de campeonatos
nacionais Esporte amador e eventualmente
cheguei a montar os meus próprios times
de futebol e vôlei LGBT que aqui em São
Paulo onde a minha vontade era de
ampliar ainda mais esse espaço para
mulheres pessoas que têm outros grupos
de pessoas que quisesse praticar o
esporte nos Passos em preconceito Eu
gostei tanto esse trabalho que comecei a
usar o meu tempo livre para ajudar homem
em São Paulo com projetos voltados para
colher e vítimas da discriminação
comecei a participar de debates
seminários audiências públicas palestras
onde eu pude falar sobre a minha
vivência com machismo e aprendendo muito
sobrevivência dos outros isso olhando
também espaço cada vez maior na minha
vida profissional com projetos são de
foco é ter um mercado de trabalho cada
vez mais inclusivo e mais com O que diz
que preconceito pode ter no ambiente
profissional
conversas que eu pessoalmente nunca tive
na minha família é minha carreira e que
eu nem imaginava que poderia ter é muito
legal ver que assim debate que tá
crescendo e tá claro que alguma coisa
tem que mudar o que ficou muito claro
para mim nesses últimos anos é que essa
mudança para mim só condição na prática
quando ela partiu de dentro para fora
esse meu exercício de desintoxicação
dessa masculinidade tóxica começou
justamente quando reconhecer em mim
entende o impacto que ela tinha na minha
vida e podia ter na vida dos outros eu
me comprometi a dar um jeito nisso e eu
sei que assim como todo mundo ainda tem
uma estrada longa de autoconhecimento
pela frente mas se eu já pudesse dividir
algum aprendizado que eu tive nesses
últimos anos para quem tem interesse em
fazer exercícios parecido tem três
práticas tem me ajudado muito nesse
processo e que podem ser um bom para os
partidos A primeira é de realmente parar
para pensar no que a gente entende como
masculino já que podem ser várias coisas
mas se elas estão de alguma forma ainda
associadas à e do homem macho sério
duram como sempre foi para mim o que me
ajudou muito foi aprender aqui na vida
real isso não é nem sustentável e nem
saudável faz parte da vida de todo homem
se sentir inseguro frágil precisar pedir
ajuda e da mesma forma como tá tudo bem
falar sobre isso tá tudo bem senti isso
também
é a segunda prática é de começar a
presta atenção naquilo que a gente fala
ou compartilha para não acabar
perpetuando essa máquina idade tóxico às
vezes De forma inconsciente com algum
comentário uma piada um elogio que a
gente faz que no fundo acaba em pondo
aqueles códigos de comportamento como
condição para o homem ser homem ou então
quando a gente simplesmente ainda acho
que nesse jeito de homem de fazer as
coisas que olhar para solo para cuidar
EA terceira e última prática tem me
ajudado muito nesse processo é de
procurar em uma direção que vai além de
simplesmente tolerar ou aceitar aquilo
que não é o que eu aprendi com um jeito
certo e vamos Eu acho que o mais legal
aqui é reconhecer o valor que tem o que
é a parte do momento em que a gente
passa a valorizar e alimentar a
liberdade de um outro homem tem nesses
folhas aí você como ele quiser a gente
passa a alimentar essa mesma liberdade
na gente o e fui respeitando a sua
liberdade de mim que eu fui entender
depois de tanto tempo que aquele defeito
Irreversível na minha masculinidade que
sempre achei que eu tinha na prática era
só meu próprio preconceito era só minha
própria masculinidade tóxica e que
apesar dela sempre defeito parte como
que eu fui ela já não faz parte do homem
que procura essa daqui pra frente e
[Aplausos]
[Música]